welcome to Horry subs the Jenna where we
discussed the latest tech news and delve
into newest tech products today we're
taking a look at if you guys should wait
for the gtx in 1180 based on the rumors
and leaks that are out about that car
right now but before we delve into that
make sure to hit that subscribe button
if you guys like to be updated with
latest tech news related to gaming and
pcs so first of all how much is this new
GPU gonna cost because that's definitely
the overarching category when deciding
whether or not to wait for a new GPU
well according to this leak this new GPU
is supposed to come out for an MSRP of
six hundred and ninety nine dollars so
if you guys remember that was the same
MSRP at the GTX 1080 founders edition
came out as well and then third party
renditions of the GTX 1080p mo for an
MSRP of $599 so this generation you may
see that ASIS gigabyte and msi variants
of this card would release for an MSRP
of $599 honestly I thought that the MSRP
of this new card would be much higher
like $800 or $850 or some like that
because of the cryptocurrency mining
issue the high demand for GPUs and
inflation of RAM prices but apparently
not according to leaked the performance
of the gtx 1180 should be very similar
to titan XP and the MSRP of the Titan XP
is $1200 and right now you'd be lucky if
you can find it for less than $1500 so
as a result the gtx 1180 is really
offering great value for its price it's
pretty much giving you the performance
of a Titan XP for less than half the
price NVIDIA is known for giving us
great generational gaps and upgrades
between generations so this is
definitely reasonable and expectable
from Nvidia also I know there are going
to be a lot of comments down below that
are like GPUs will never return to MSRP
until RAM prices subside but Ram prices
have been increasing for over a year now
and NVIDIA GPUs have only been
increasing in price since the beginning
of this year also grande prices were
much higher in November in December of
2017 but the GPUs oven video were
actually
MSRP and oftentimes even lower than MSRP
so as a result I don't think ramp prices
effect into GPU market too dramatically
now Before we jump into all the numbers
and stuff I think we should first take
the time to understand the real-world
performance that this gtx 1180 will
offer so assuming that it is very
similar to Titan XP it should be able to
handle all current games at max settings
at least 60 frames per second at 4k it
should actually be able to handle most
games at 70 or 80 frames or even higher
on top of that it should also really
excel in triple monitor 1080p gaming and
ultra wide q HD gaming and other
variants like that so if you guys are
interested in any of those gaming Dallas
then this new GPU may be worth
considering and waiting for first of all
this new GPU is going to go from the
Pascal architecture to the tearing
architecture which means a change in the
process from a 16 nanometer process to a
12 nanometer FinFET process on top of
this this gtx 1180 thers expected a huge
die size increase as for the gtx 1080
the die size was 314 millimeters squared
and for this new card it's supposed to
be 400 millimeters squared so it is
quite a big increase however the
performance is more than worth it asked
for CUDA cores the GTX 1080 has 2560
cuda cores and this new GT 1180 is
supposed to have 3584 cuda cores and to
put this in perspective the Titan XP has
3840 cuda cores so it's very comparable
with the gtx 1180 on top of this when
you look at teraflops the gtx 1080 has
8.7 teraflops of performance the Titan
XP has 12 and this new gtx 1180 is
supposed to have 13th teraflops the gtx
1080 has 8 gigabytes of gddr5 X memory
and the Titan XP has 12 gigabytes of
gddr5 X memory but this new graphics
card is supposed to have anywhere from 8
to 16 gigabytes of RAM but it's supposed
to be GT dr6 memory which is supposed to
offer exponentially better performance
than the gddr5 X memory
unfortunately it is rumoured to be a bit
pricier though as for memory speed the
GTX 1080 has 10 gigabit per second
memory speed the Titan XP has eleven
point four gigabit per second memory
speed and this new gtx 1180 is supposed
to have 16 bits per second memory speed
as for memory or bandwidth the gtx 1080
has 320 gigabytes per second the titan
XP has five hundred and forty seven
point seven gigabytes a second and this
new gtx lemonade is supposed to have 512
gigabytes a second on top of all of this
the gtx 1180 is supposed to consume less
power than the titan XP the gtx 1180 is
rumored to only consume 170 to 200 watts
while the titan XP consumed at 250 watts
overall the leaked performance and
benchmarks at the gtx 1180 put it very
close with the titan XP and with the new
ddr contexture this may lead to almost
identical performance with the titan XP
so that's all the information that there
is but should you wait in my opinion I
definitely recommend that you guys wait
if you have the money because this new
gtx 1180 just gives so much better
performance and it's a much better value
also you'd be spending the same amount
of money that you would be on GT x 1080
right now so it's definitely worth the
price so that's for the gtx 1180 but
what about for the lower level cards
like the 1160 and 1170 well we don't
have any performance numbers on them or
price leaks so the only thing we can do
is look at past generations to be able
to predict the performance of these new
GPUs so last generation the 1070 was
pretty much equal with the 980ti in
terms of performance it was actually
just a little bit better so this
generation we may see that the 1170 is
pretty much identical with the 1080 Ti
also last generation the 1060 was pretty
much equal with the 980 so this
generation the 1160 should be very
comparable with the 1080 and as for
price I think that the price will remain
the same considering that the gtx 1180
is offered for the same price if
anything it may be bumped up like 10 to
20 dollars like will happen with the
intel i7 8
700k so honestly these new GPUs are
going to offer much better performance
at a much cheaper price so I really
think that all of you guys should wait
if you can even if you just want a ten
serious card and you don't really care
about all the new performance that these
new cards come with you just still wait
because once these new cards come out
the ten series cards will further drop
in the price and you guys can save money
then so overall in my opinion the only
reason that you wouldn't wait for these
new cards is because you really don't
care about a little bit more performance
or a little bit of money that you guys
could save and there's no shame in that
either so what do you guys think do you
guys think that the gtx 1180 is going to
be awesome and definitely worth waiting
for and that it'll deliver that much
performance or do you think that that
much performance is definitely overkill
and quite pointless make sure to comment
down below what you guys think about
this because I do read all my comments
and I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video then
make sure drop a like and if you guys
would like to see more videos just like
this every single day and make sure to
hit that subscribe button and turn on
that Bell notification but until next
time bye
[Music]